[Music]
okay
foreign
foreign
all good
um
so
three two one
this hearing will now come to order
this hearing is in a hybrid format and
the hearing room has been configured to
maintain the recommended six foot social
distancing between senators
witnesses and other individuals in the
room necessary to operate the hearing
which we have kept to a minimum
for those joining remo remotely a few
video conferencing reminders which you
should all be very familiar with at this
point
once you start speaking there will be a
slight delay before you're displayed on
the screen
to minimize background noise please
click the mute button until it is your
turn to speak or ask questions
if there is a technology issue we will
move to the next senator until it is
resolved
once again i remind all senators and our
witnesses that the five-minute clock
still applies
those remote should have on your screen
one of the boxes labeled clock that will
show how much time is remaining
we've had some trouble getting those
boxes on everybody's screen apparently
or at least getting everybody to be able
to find them and follow them
and so we are going to continue a
practice that we started
at the last hearing at 30 seconds
remaining you will hear a bell
ring to remind senators that their time
has almost expired
i encourage the senators and our
witnesses to
recognize that bill and wrap things up
on the
answers as well as the questions in time
to
keep within the five minutes
to simplify the speaking order process
senator brown and i have again agreed to
go by seniority in this hearing
today we welcome the witnesses to the
committee to provide testimony as
required
under title four of the cares act
our witnesses are the honorable stephen
t minutian
secretary of the department of treasury
and the honorable jerome h
powell chairman of the board of
governors of the federal reserve system
welcome to both of you on november 19
treasury secretary mnuchin requested for
the federal reserve to return unused
funds that had been appropriated under
title iv of the cares act for thirteen
three facilities and direct loans
i agree with secretary mnuchin on the
success of the thirteen
three facilities and the termination
language in the cares act
the thirteen three facilities funded
under the cares act were effective
and fulfilled their purpose to stabilize
markets
facilitate credit flow and provide
liquidity
all of these programs were created in an
emergency at the onset of the pandemic
when the financial markets were in
danger of melting down
that the programs worked
even as the pandemic and government
shutdowns have waxed and waned
financial markets have healed lending
spreads have fallen
and liquidity is ample in nearly all
markets
the most recent federal
tests said
facility and municipal liquidity
facility in late march and early april
led to a wrap led to rapid improvements
in corporate
and municipal bond markets well ahead of
the facility's
actual opening the report also said
since the announcement of the backstop
facilities and funding market
stabilization measures
more than one trillion dollars in new
non-financial corporate bonds and more
than 250 billion dollars
in municipal debt have been issued
purchased almost entirely
by the private sector with respect to
asset-backed securities
the report noted that similar to other
backstop facilities
while outstanding balances in the term
asset-backed securities facility
have remained modest spreads in the
asset backed securities market have
narrowed considerably
and private market issuance has resumed
with just one month until the december
31 termination date only 195 billion
dollars of the 454 billion dollars
needed to be allocated to the 133
facilities
and those facilities have not been
extensively used today
returning the unused 455 billion dollars
to treasury now
allows those funds to be made available
for other important purposes
such as providing more targeted relief
to sectors of the economy that
need it most or to reducing the national
debt
the cares act funding supported these
facilities
supporting these facilities was always
intended to be temporary
additionally as was mentioned in both
secretary mnuchin and
chairman powell's letters the exchange
stabilization fund still has non-cares
act funds that are available to the
extent permitted by law
to capitalize any federal reserve
lending facilities
as needed in fact the fed has four
facilities that were set up with
non-cares act funds including the
commercial paper facility
and money market liquidity facility
although covid 19 continues to spread
across the united states and the world
there is hope in the economic recovery
that we have seen so far
and the reports of promising highly
effective vaccine trials
however we continue to look to steps
that we can take to help americans and
businesses that need it the most
republicans have tried for months to get
another targeted bipartisan coveted
relief package passed and signed into
law
to provide support for those in need
but democrats have rejected those
efforts
it is time to find agreement where we
can on a targeted
bipartisan basis provide relief
turning for a moment to regulations the
cares act included other meaningful
pandemic related programs to provide
relief to americans
i've heard from banks and credit unions
concerned about breaking through
regulatory thresholds that stand to
impose a much greater regulatory
burden due to the temporary growth
they've experienced from customer
deposits and participation
in pandemic related programs like the
paycheck protection program and the
economic impact payments
on november 20 the fed fdic and occ took
an important step
to mitigating banks regulatory burden by
giving community banks
under 10 billion dollars more
flexibility to use their asset size on
december 31 2019
for applying various regulations i
appreciate the banking agencies taking
this action which will foster a more
certain regulatory environment for these
banks
and incentivize their participation in
future pandemic-related programs
should they be needed secretary mnuchin
as you know housing finance reform
remains a top priority of mine
and last year i released a housing
reform outline which builds upon many of
the same principles
from previous efforts while my
preference was for congress to pass a
bipartisan deal
it is long past time to make the hard
decisions and address this last
unfinished business of the financial
crisis
because of that i would encourage you
and the director of the fhfa
to continue to take important steps that
move the system in the right direction
the status quo continues to be
unacceptable
i want to thank each of you for joining
the committee today to discuss the cares
act and other critically important
issues
before i turn to senator brown for his
opening i also want to take some time to
thank both senators mcsally and
jones for their contribution and time to
this committee
i've enjoyed working with them spending
time with them and getting to know them
and they will be missed i wish you both
the best
and finally i want to thank senator
brown and his staff for the time we've
worked together on this committee
i've appreciated our time together on
this committee and our friendship
even if at times we may not have seen
eye to eye
senator brown uh thank you mr chairman i
uh welcome secretary mnuchin
uh and chairman powell good to have both
of you here
i'd like to um second what uh gerald
crapo just said i
want to thank doug jones and and martha
mcsally for their
service on this committee they both
contributed a great deal thank you and
uh thank you since this is chair krepo's
um last hearing i believe thank you for
your on this committee thank you for
your leadership decency and
patience mike you can run but you can't
hide since i also
uh serve with you obviously in the
finance committee i want to thank
your staff director greg richard for his
work and the rest of your staff
laura in our office and working together
has been really meaningful and
productive
we've worked together to deliver results
working to strengthen our review of
foreign investment to hold russia and
north korea accountable
to give american manufacturers the tools
they need to compete through a strong
exim bank
and to continue to protect our
communities from terrorism attacks
i look forward next year to working with
our colleague
senator toomey on these and other issues
i i
also appreciate chair crapo and his
staff's work to hold so many of our
hearings virtually during this pandemic
protecting the people who work in the
capitol from the virus should not be a
partisan issue
uh on this committee it largely has not
been i wish i could say the same
uh throughout this building and
throughout the senate
it's something i wish there were more of
in it with our government
uh chairpile sector revolution the two
months since your last year the
situation around the country
has only gotten worse the virus is
spreading unchecked
job losses are up economic growth is
declining
the number of new daily coveted 19 cases
is up four-fold
daily deaths have more than doubled in
many parts of the country the case
numbers and hospitalizations are worse
than in the spring
i spent much of yesterday talking to
hospital
leaders around my state all are
all feel besieged all are doing their
work the health care workers surely as
we know
our heroes we simply don't give them
enough support
just last week 748 000 people filed for
unemployment insurance
millions more have been out of work
since april in october
3.4 million million homeowners were
passed due
on their mortgages many of them will run
out of forbearance
as many 40 million renters will spend
the holidays worrying
that they will be evicted on january 1st
if they're if their government
if we don't if their government doesn't
do its job
behind all those numbers are real
families who are doing their best trying
to figure out how to get by
during thanksgiving week there are hours
long lines and food banks across the
country
this is an extraordinary crisis that
requires extraordinary action
we've had a president who has simply
given up on leading the country
and as far as i can tell secretary
mnuchin you're leaving the country worse
off
than you found it with that record it's
pretty obvious why 80 million americans
voted for new leadership a decisive
margin
and other than using your final office's
final months in office to work for the
people whom you have sworn to serve you
appear to be trying to sabotage our
economy on the way out the door
after the election you cancel the
federal reserve lending programs taking
away critical tools
to invest in the people in the
communities and the small businesses
that make this country work there is no
legitimate justification
for it i met yesterday with 60
restaurant owners
by remotely by zoom 60 restaurant owners
in this state
on my state all of them are struggling
as you know
either you're purposely trying to stop
president-elect biden
and treasury's secretary designee yellen
from getting to work for the people we
all serve
or you're delusional that you think
because the stock market is up
and i understand taking the lead from
the president that when the stock
market's up everywhere everything is
fine
either way you either way it's
malpractice it was only the end of
october when you finally reduced the
minimum loan size
to the main steep street program to a
hundred thousand dollars so the program
would actually
work for small businesses and
communities but now after all the
waiting and adjusting the main street
program
finally gets going you take away another
tool to help american businesses and
workers
even the policy he had at the chamber of
commerce said that shutting down the
emergency lending programs quote
closes the door on important liquidity
options
for businesses at a time when they need
the most unquote
it's always the same story as you know
mr secretary when the biggest banks and
the largest corporations need help
their allies in washington spring into
action
when the rest of the country needs
investment and support you want to
pretend we just can't afford it
you cited congressional intent is a
flimsy justification for your decision
i can tell you right now we didn't
intend for struggling businesses
to have to wait over three months to
have access to the lifeline
providing the cares act we didn't intend
for the loan requirements
terms to be amended several times we
certainly didn't intend
for the legislation passed in march to
be the only efforts
the united states of america would take
to fight a once-in-a-generation
crisis anyone who's watched the news at
all in the last month would know that
this is the time for action
not for retreat we watch hospitals fill
up again our health care system is
overwhelmed gig workers
self-employed workers lose their
unemployment insurance
just in five weeks small four weeks
small businesses local governments are
running out of money it didn't have to
be this bad
we have the world's largest greatest
economy we have the resources to rise to
meet the challenge
but secretary mnuchin you appear to
believe this is the best we can do
in this election americans made it clear
they didn't buy that
they've had enough of aiming load being
told we can't afford it we can't solve
problems we can't govern
we can't do this we know we can do
better we've done it before remember
what bill spriggs
uh in front of this committee said in
september we didn't
win world war ii by worrying about
whether or not we could afford it
we were in a global crisis we marshaled
all of our vast resources and talent to
rise to meet it
we grew the economy from the middle
class out we paid down the debt with
rising wages
and if we've learned anything from this
crisis it should be this that we can do
the same thing again remember what we
did in march
unanimously mr chairman we came together
we took action and made a real
difference in people's lives
in the face of mass layoffs we put money
in people's pockets
we help them pay their bills we kept
spending in this economy
we kept 13 million people out of poverty
those restaurant owners yesterday in
ohio said their situation is more
perilous today than it was back
in february and march and april and may
so it means that we should do
a comparable kind of action
and what we did in march helped everyone
including the stock market that you love
to brag about
there's no reason other than a lack of
political will that we can't do the same
a worker's about to about to lose her
job doesn't care about the
dead date on the calendar who's sitting
at the secretary's desk
they care about results secretary
mnuchin if you and president trump won't
deliver
them the least you can do is get out of
the way i know chair powell has been
clear in previous hearings we need
generally have any answers real broad
economic recovery
need of extend this package one that
reaches beyond wall street
that's the sort of emaciated uh
mcconnell version
reached beyond wall street to main
streets in cleveland and boise
and scranton and and all over this
country that shows up in people's
paychecks not just corporate balance
sheets i hope today the american people
will get reassurance that the federal
reserve
will be part of that effort it's time
for all of us to use every tool
available to rise to meet this challenge
thank you mr sheridan thank you senator
brown we'll now proceed to our witnesses
we will go in the order i introduced you
and secretary mnuchin you may proceed
thank you chairman crepo ranking member
brown and members of the committee
i'm pleased to join you to discuss the
department of treasury's unprecedented
response
to support the american people
throughout the coronavirus pandemic
we continue to work to implement the
historic cares act with speed
efficiency and transparency but our job
will not be complete until every
american gets back to work
when i last testified before you in
september i stated that america was in
the midst of the fastest economic
recovery from any crisis
in u.s history i'm proud to say while
there is still more work to be done
that statement is even more true today
in the third quarter gdp grew by 33
percent
at an annual rate beating all
expectations in nearly doubling the
previous record
set in 1950 americans are getting back
to work the october jobs report showed
that the economy
has gained back 12 million jobs since
april more than 50 percent
of all lost jobs due to the pandemic the
private service
sector which includes those industries
that were impacted by the initial
economic shutdown
has regained 58 of the lost jobs
the unemployment rate decreased to 6.9
percent a rate not expected to be
achieved
until the fourth quarter of 2021
the historic bipartisan cares act
provided the economic relief critical
to supporting our robust economy
additional economic shutdowns however
continue to
impair this remarkable progress and
cause great harm to american business
and workers
based upon the recent economic data i
continue to believe
that a targeted fiscal package is the
most appropriate
federal response i strongly encourage
congress to use
the 455 billion dollars in unused funds
from the cares act
to pass an additional bill with
bipartisan support
the administration is standing ready to
support congress in this effort to help
american workers in small business
that continue to struggle with the
impact of covet 19.
treasury has been working hard to
implement the cares act in a transparent
and efficient manner we've released
significant amount of information to the
public on our website
treasury.gov and on usaspending.gov
in many instances we've released more
information than what is required by the
statute
we continue to cooperate with various
oversight bodies including the new
special
inspector general the treasury inspector
general
the treasury inspector general for tax
administration
the new congressional oversight
commission the gao
we have provided regular updates to
congress with this marking my eighth
appearance
before congress for a cares act hearing
we've also devoted significant resources
to responding to numerous congressional
committees and individual members of
congress
on both sides of the aisle we appreciate
your interest on these issues
we remain committed to working with you
to accommodate congress's
legislative requests and to further
advance our whole of government approach
to defeating covet 19. i'd like to thank
the members of the committee for working
with us to provide
critical economic relief to the american
people and i'm pleased to be here to
answer any questions
thank you chairman powell
chairman crapo ranking member brown and
other members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to update
you on our ongoing measures to address
the hardship
brought by the pandemic pardon me
our public health professionals continue
to deliver our most important response
and we remain grateful for their service
the federal reserve along with others
across government
is using its policies to help alleviate
the economic burden
since the pandemics onset we have taken
forceful actions to provide relief and
stability
to ensure that the recovery will be as
strong as possible
and to limit lasting damage to the
economy
economic activity has continued to
recover from its depressed second
quarter level
the reopening of the economy led to a
rapid rebound in activity and real gdp
rose at an annual rate of 33 percent in
the third quarter
in recent months however the pace of
improvement has moderated household
spending on goods
especially durable goods has been strong
and has moved above
its pre-pandemic level in contrast
spending on services remains low
largely because of ongoing weakness in
sectors that typically require people to
gather
closely including travel and hospitality
the overall rebound in household
spending is due in part to federal
stimulus payments and expanded
unemployment benefits
which provided essential support to many
families and individuals
in the labor market more than half of
the 22 million jobs that were lost in
march and april have been regained
as many people were able to return to
work
as with overall economic activity the
pace of improvement
in the labor market has moderated
although we welcome this progress we
will not lose sight of the millions of
americans who remain out of work
the economic downturn has not fallen
equally on all americans and those
least able to bear to shoulder the
burden have been hardest hit
in particular the high level of
joblessness has been especially severe
for lower wage workers in the service
sector for women and for
african-americans and hispanics
the economic dislocation has upended
many lives and created great uncertainty
about the future
as we've emphasized throughout the
pandemic the outlook for the economy is
extraordinarily uncertain and will
depend in large part on the success of
efforts to keep
the virus in check the rise in new coven
19 cases both here and abroad is
concerning and could prove challenging
in the next few months a full economic
recovery is unlikely until people are
confident that it's safe to re-engage in
a broad range of activities
recent news on the vaccine front is very
positive for the medium term
for now significant challenges
challenges and uncertainty remain
including the timing production and
distribution
and efficacy across different groups it
remains difficult to assess the timing
and scope
of the economic implications of these
developments with any degree of
confidence
the fed's response has been guided by
our mandate to promote maximum
employment and stable prices for the
american people
along with our responsibilities to
promote the stability of the financial
system
we've been taking broad and forceful
actions to more directly support the
flow of credit and the economy
our actions taken together have helped
unlock almost
two trillion dollars of funding to
support businesses large and small
non-profits and state and local
governments since april
this in turn has helped keep
organizations from shuddering and has
put employers in a better position
to keep workers on and to hire them back
as the economy continues to recover
these programs serve as a backstop to
key credit markets and have helped
restore the flow of credit from private
lenders through normal channels
we've deployed these lending powers to
an unprecedented extent
our emergency lending powers require the
approval of the treasury
and a reverel available only in very
unusual circumstances
such as those we find ourselves in many
of these programs have been supported by
funding from the
cares act and i've included detailed
information about those facilities in my
written testimony the cares act assigns
sole authority over its funds to the
treasury secretary subject to the
statute's specified limits
the secretary has indicated that these
limits do not permit cares act funded
facilities to make new loans or purchase
new assets after december 31
of this year accordingly the federal
reserve will return the unused portion
of funds
allocated to the lending programs that
are backstopped by the cares act
in connection with their termination at
the end of the year
as the secretary noted in his letter
non-cares act funds in the exchange
stabilization fund
are available to support emergency
lending facilities if they are needed
everything the fed does is in service to
our public mission
we're committed to using our full range
of tools to support the economy and to
help assure that the recovery from this
difficult period
will be as robust as possible on behalf
of communities
families and businesses across the
country thank you
thank you chairman powell my first
question i
think will be toward you secretary
munich i'm
actually quite surprised to hear you
criticized for following the law
and how you have dealt with the return
of the cares act funds that
we we were in the room together
negotiating these provisions
as the care cares act was created
and interestingly it seems to me that
the real problem here
is well you'll recall uh you
and we were accused of creating a big
slush fund
and now when we have terminated
these funds as required by the law so
that we can utilize them
more effectively in the next act the
criticism is that this fund should not
have been terminated
i just find that kind of confusing
that's also confusing in the context of
the fact that we have tried to gut
the kind the very kind of relief in
follow-up legislation
that that we've now been criticized for
not doing
just a few months ago extending things
like the paycheck protection program
which would help those restaurant
workers that senator brown mentioned
extending and improving it by the way
redirecting some of these funds
so that we get to those industries and
sectors of our economy that have not yet
been reached by the 13-3 facilities and
really need to have a different kind of
direct support
system put into place for them
adding rental assistance that we need to
have
in my opinion and which i've been
working very hard on to try to get
and as we tried to get these things they
were rejected by the other side
and so it's just confusing to me or a
little bit surprising
to see these kinds of attacks leveled
today in this hearing
and so secretary mnuchin could you just
help
make a little sense from your point of
view as to why the decision
to make to the return of these funds
away from the 13 3 facilities at this
time
is the best thing and what the intent
that you had
was in making that termination
thank you mr chairman and let me first
say uh
i want to thank the senate for passing
the cares act which was 96 to zero
in an unprecedented response and and as
you know
i lived in the lbj room for over
two weeks so i'm very familiar i
personally negotiated
many of these provisions matter of fact
i brought the cares act with me
because i reference it and keep it next
to my desk
and mr chairman i would just uh ask you
to recall
you and i were sitting outside senator
schumer's office with his staff
he was after one a.m in the morning on
the night that we finally finished this
and i asked you to come to sign off on
on behalf of the leader and others
uh the final red lines we went through
this very carefully so i would direct
you
to section 4029 which is very clear
which says accept is provided in
subsection b
on december 31 2020 the authority
provided under the subtitle
uh shall terminate it was very clear
uh so my decision uh first of all i want
to
thank chair powell because he has been a
terrific partner in everything we've
done
uh and i really want to thank him and
the people
at the fed uh he and i
have been speaking constantly in
deference to him
i did extend the four of the facilities
that use non-cares money
my decision not to extend these
facilities was not an
economic decision i'm surprised to hear
senator brown use words like sabotage no
legitimate
justification delusional malpractice
time for action i'd be more than happy
senator brown to come seeing your staff
and walk you through the legal analysis
but this is
perfectly clear the senate
provided unprecedented authority to the
secretary of the treasury and giving me
500 billion dollars
the statute was very clear matter of
fact i find it implausible that any
member of this committee
believed that in voting for the cares
act you were authorizing me to invest
500 billion dollars to make loans in
perpetuity
so if you don't read this as there is an
expiration
then you must read this that there was a
loophole
in the law that i could invest the 500
billion dollars
forever had i committed up front and i i
don't believe that was the intent i
would also just conclude
i echo what senator brown said about
restaurants
uh the president i believe that
restaurants have been unfairly targeted
and i'd urge congress to support another
300 billion dollars for ppp this would
have a real impact
these restaurants need grants they don't
need loans thank you
thank you and uh as you can tell by the
bell chairman powell
i don't have time to ask you my
questions but i will have you respond to
them
either later in the hearing or else i'll
send them to you in writing
senator brown thank you mr chairman i
i um secretary mnuchin i see by your
testimony today you really don't
understand what's happening in families
across our country almost
celebrating your marvelous work of you
and the president
that the country so desi decisively
rejected
uh the the the one of my favorite
abraham lincoln quotes is he used to
talk about going out and
getting his public opinion back it's
pretty clear
i appreciate what you said about
restaurants but it's pretty clear that
you have left behind the
administration's left behind the
president
is only concerned about um seeing
something that's not there fraud in an
election
as so many republican judges and
a few a few a few courageous republican
office holders have spoken out against
about
on our last hearing i ask you and
secretary powell to read a piece by pro
publica about a small business owner in
cleveland whose business couldn't get
help
while the giant corporation occupying
the same building has gotten plenty of
taxpayer support
while laying off its workers i'm hoping
i'm hoping you would have read it
and made a more serious effort to
understand what's happening
in places like cleveland and mansfield
and shelby and springfield ohio
millions of american workers are still
struggling
millions more are out of work all the
numbers
are going in the wrong direction you
wouldn't have
wouldn't you wouldn't determine that
from from your comments today it's clear
you were never serious about fighting
i sat in that room too uh in the lbj
room it's clear you were never
serious about fighting for the bill
people who make the country work instead
of making a deal
that would have done more to help them
you push to make life just a little bit
easier for the nation's biggest banks
now you've
killed the cares act loans that were
supposed to be a tool to help smaller
businesses and their workers
and and buried the money looks like you
and the president
um and others in the current
administration are trying to spend your
final days
in office preemptively i'll use that
word again sabotaging the next
administration's efforts
to clean up your mess but you still work
for the american people even though
i don't think you're acting like a
secretary minutian i wish you an
administration would stop growing about
the stock market and and stop passing
the buck
instead of doing the hard work uh
president-elect biden and your success
will have to fix the mess you're leaving
behind now my question is for chairman
powell
george paul you were around the
beginning of the next you'll be around
the beginning next administration you'll
be part of the cleanup crew you've made
clear
and i appreciate the conversations we've
had where you've made clear that
congress needs to do more fiscal support
we've also committed recently that even
if we take bold action
we're not going back to the same economy
and then it will be more difficult for
workers going forward so my question is
this we've seen how the fed
and treasury action supported the stock
market and benefited the wealthiest
people in this country
what can the fed do on chair powell to
make sure that workers don't get left
behind again
thank you senator brown so i would say
this we
we have provided and will continue to
provide very strong support for the
economy and for workers in particular
through the use of our tools and we
remain committed to using all of our
tools
uh to their fullest extent for as long
as is necessary
to get us through this uh this difficult
period
we've thought about this uh collective
effort this government-wide effort
uh as one that involves getting the
people
and and the businesses that constitute
the economy across
the chasm created by uh you know
by the pandemic getting them safely to
the other side to the post-pandemic
economy
and um i think um frankly the
the the fiscal uh policy particularly
the cares act deserves the lion's share
of
the credit in creating that bridge so
far it may be that we need
we need more on that front but from the
standpoint of the fed you can be sure
that we'll continue to use our tools
and by the way those tools would include
section
3 facilities which remain available to
us under the law and as the secretary
pointed out in his letter
they can be backed up by exchange
stabilization funds should the legal
requirements for such funds be
met sure paul does the fed have an
obligation
to address the problems of in inequality
uh that many argue that actions have
amplified especially in addressing
inequality in communities of color
but so i think inequality is a very
important and
um ever more broadly understood problem
in our economy these persistent
disparities
along racial and and gender and other
lines
really hold our economy back i think
that um
the fed has a contribution to make there
it is not the principal contribution i
think
that really fiscal policy and congress
has
and and uh in the private sector too
have have very important roles there
what we can do is a lot of what we're
doing which is to focus on maximum
employment
which is your order to us uh that that's
that's the goal you've set forth for us
and to really take that
idea seriously and i think you've seen
with the most recent uh
modifications to our operating framework
that we are taking it seriously and and
focusing on these issues
more as holding the whole economy back
thank you mr chairman thank you and
before we go to senator toomey i just
have to say uh
secretary madison you've been accused of
killing the cares act loans for small
businesses
i i think that's mostly the ppp program
which we tried to re-energize
and extend on the floor of the senate
only to have it killed
by the other side when we were trying to
do that but we'll continue to have these
debates back and forth
turn next to senator toomey thank you
very much mr chairman and uh
mr chairman as this might be the last
banking committee
hearing of your chairmanship i do want
to thank you for your leadership and the
really hard work and outstanding work
you've done thank you it's a pleasure
working
with you um what i want to do is first
of all i want to applaud
secretary mnuchin for closing the 13
3 facilities by year-end exactly as the
law requires
and as congress clearly intended i want
to thank chairman powell
for returning the unused cares funds
back to the treasury fact is congress
entrusted both
of you with some extremely powerful
unprecedented emergency and yet
temporary
tools and i commend you for working
together
to deploy those tools for their intended
purposes
and then putting them away now that that
specific purpose has been achieved and i
think it's important to
review what was happening and why we
designed the cares act as we did
the fact is in march we had
unprecedented turmoil in our capital
markets
threatening the ability of businesses
municipalities states to achieve
to access capital and credit credit
markets were on the verge of completely
freezing up
there was a mass investor flight to cash
in many cases there were no buyers in
sight
private credit wasn't flowing uh to to
any institutions that needed it
and this freezing of our financial
system
was a very serious threat that it could
precipitate a full-blown depression that
would last for who knows how long
kent heightshaw the deputy associate
director for financial stability at the
fed
noted in a congressional oversight
testimony and i want to quote because he
summarizes this very well he said the
conditions that prevailed
in march were unprecedented far worse
than during the onset of the financial
crisis in late 2008
or even in the days after 9 11 when the
municipal market was briefly closed
interest rates soared mutual fund
investors pulled over 41 billion dollars
of assets out of the market
in less than three weeks and market
functioning deteriorated to the point
that buyers and sellers had difficulty
determining prices
ultimately this meant that state and
local governments were effectively
unable to borrow
with most new issues cancelled the lack
of investor demand
end quote mr chairman that was the
problem
that congress was seeking to address to
solve
by providing the cares act funding for
temporary emergency
facilities congress's intent was clear
the facilities were designed to create a
liquidity backstop until the crisis
passed
and then cease operations no later than
the end of 2020 in any case
last week i would point out that every
republican on this committee
signed a letter sent to secretary
mnuchin and chairman powell
affirming that this is in fact our
interpretation of the law
and the intent of congress i also think
it's important to underscore
how remarkably successful these
facilities were in achieving
that intended purpose of stabilizing
credit markets and restoring the flow
of private credit in fact it worked
better than i think
most of us thought even possible markets
didn't just
improve they didn't just restore
liquidity
but we reached record volumes of debt
issuance
we did so at low spreads low yields
affordable interest rates regional banks
extended credit to their customers
and according to business surveys unmet
demand for credit among creditworthy
borrowers is almost non-existent
so let me go through some of the
arguments that we've heard for why we
should not have
closed down these facilities because i
think they're all mistaken
one was that the viability of the credit
markets
depends on these backstop facilities
well that's clearly been disproven by
the fact that the announcement
of their end brought absolutely no
disruption to any financial markets
that i can tell at all the second
suggestion by some is that well
we need to keep these facilities around
because you know some bad thing might
happen someday in the future
well it's always been the case that you
could imagine some bad thing happening
in the future
um if some terrible thing were to happen
to threaten the viability of our
financial markets
then the treasury and the fed should
come back to congress and ask for
appropriate facilities at that time
others point out that there are whole
industries that are actually in big big
trouble that is a true fact especially
travel and hospitality and entertainment
um
where consumer demand has basically
disappeared
it's up to congress to decide what to do
about that it is not up to the fed
to lend money to what are probably
insolvent companies
so let's be clear these facilities were
designed for a very specific purpose
they achieved that purpose more
successfully than we could have
reasonably hoped
and we should not use them to morph into
some other
purpose like as a supplement and or
complement
to fiscal policy i want to thank the
chairman
and the treasury secretary for really
the outstanding work they did
in helping to ensure the viability of
our financial markets and thereby avoid
a prolonged depression thank you senator
timmy
senator reid thank you very much mr
chairman
let me thank secretary mnuchin and
chairman al
for being here today chairman powell in
your november 5th
press conference you said the fiscal
policy actions that have been taken thus
far
have made a critical difference to
families businesses and communities
across the country
even so the current economic downturn is
most severe in our lifetime
it will take a while to get back to the
levels of economic activity
and employment that prevailed at the
beginning of this year
and it may take continued support from
both monetary
and fiscal policy to achieve that jim
paul
how long will it take us to get back to
the pre-covet level of economic activity
and employment
without any further physical relief this
year from congress
it would be very difficult to uh to say
uh
how that would play out in terms of the
time i i will say though that
um first of all the economy has actually
performed better than expected it's been
more resilient to
uh spikes in cases than than expected
nonetheless and we've so we've had a
recovery that's been faster than
most forecasters have expected so far
nonetheless we do have a long way to go
we've got on the order of 10 million
people who lost their jobs because of
the pandemic
and for for reference that's more than
lost their jobs during the global
financial crisis in the united states so
it's a lot of people so there's a long
way to go and it's
i think we can we can both acknowledge
the progress
uh and also uh and point out just just
how far we have left to go and as i
said as i said earlier the lion's share
of the credit really should go to fiscal
policy
and of course the you know the the
timing and the scope
and and the size and the components of
that are entirely up to you
i just point out that um we'll use our
tools uh until
uh you know until the danger is well and
truly passed
and it may require help from other parts
of government as well including
including congress
well thank you chairman paul also in
your november fifth press conference you
uh pointed out to the collective desire
to keeping this episode
short as it can be and avoiding
unnecessary business bankruptcies
unnecessary household bankruptcy
necessary long-term phase of
unemployment and there's a real threat
of those things and we're trying to do
everything we can to minimize them
um we're beginning to see that right now
several of my colleagues have alluded to
the fact that as these
eviction and foreclosure moratoriums
expire there could be
thousands of thousands of people thrown
out of their homes
which will affect i think the financial
markets uh
and in that case it might be good to
have a
facility backed by of the peers act
uh some of these issues aren't
hypothetical they're not sort of a
crisis the future that we don't see
they're very real in fact they're coming
unless we take
appropriate action and that would be i
think
fiscal action so do you think that these
threats are
are just uh sort of uh
substantial or or they're almost
dishonest
so as i as i mentioned in my uh
testimony senator i think there's a real
distinction between the near term
and the medium term in the near term
we see the spread of the disease uh we
and what we're hearing from businesses
and from we met with a
group of community bankers that we
regularly meet with a week or so ago
what we're hearing is that there are a
lot of small businesses that are at risk
of going out of business during this
winter which could be could be a tough
few months at the same time they were
getting this news about the the vaccines
which are more effective and they've
come sooner so there really is
you know in the medium term upside risk
here and and
the other thing i'll say is that the
fact that the economy was in very good
shape
at the beginning of the pandemic may
that may be one of the reasons why
it has recovered faster faster than we
thought and kind of continued to defy
uh expectations of problems so um i do
think those are real risks though i
think the risk
of small businesses going out of
business the risk of um
people at the lower end of the income
spectrum where at the bottom quartile i
think the unemployment rate is still 20
these are not people with a lot of
savings a lot of resources
or a lot of opportunities right now and
so i think that that there are
there are parts of the economy that that
really will need help
or might need help to get to get that
last span of the bridge in place to get
to the other side of the
pandemic uh
i think one of the points you're making
is that the impact of this
crisis economically is not shared
equally by all americans there are
groups that are
impoverished now and are on the edge of
even
worse disasters unless we act and if we
don't act
then we will have two separate but
unequal groups of americans and that's
not a recipe for a country that can
move forward thank you very much thank
you senator reid and before we move to
senator scott i would just indicate that
we are moving you know a few minutes
into a series of votes on the senate
floor
i'm going to leave right now to vote
early on the first vote and then return
as quickly as i can
and i've asked senator tillis who's
present here in the hearing room to
cheer for me while i am gone senator
scott thank you mr chairman before you
leave
i'd like to say to you thank you for
your leadership
on our committee you have done a
fantastic job you've listened to both
sides you've led
in a bipartisan fashion
of a nation desperate to see their
congress their senate working well and
working together and
frankly disagreeing is a part of what we
signed up for but
looking for opportunities to bring uh
the committee together
and bring this nation together i think
you have been a shining example of that
mike and i want to say
thank you for your leadership and to
chairman powell
as well as secretary mnuchin you both
have done a pretty
pretty good job under uh incredibly
negative circumstances and the situation
continues to change
certainly thank you chair powell for
your for your uh leadership
for our nation uh under these uh
challenging times secretary mnitch and
you've stepped up to the plate
and it provided uh programs and
resources in a way
that we've never seen in the history of
the country from my perspective and i
thank you for your strong leadership
with that said one of the things i've
noticed that as we've
worked our way through this pandemic
small businesses have been
struggling and frankly as a former small
business owner myself i
understand the pain and the misery of
being in small business i also
remember the thrill of victory more than
i do the agony of
defeat i remember the the blessing of
employing members from my
from my neighborhoods where i grew up
and having folks uh
join the team as customers and and
seeing the revenues increasing the
opportunities for my employees increase
and
one of the things that are is often
missing missing when we're talking to
small business owners is the
important ingredient that for most of us
our small business employees are an
extension of our family and so
when you start talking about the small
business environment
and small businesses being decimated by
this pandemic
you're actually talking about the the
fragile nature of small business
and the uh absolute implosion of the
foundation for so many employees around
the country
i think we sometimes miss the fact that
when you're talking about small business
you're actually talking about
employees who work at the small
businesses more than you are the small
business owner
to that end secretary mnuchin you
have watched as i have in chair powell
you have as well
that 20 plus percent of all small
businesses have failed
uh that number is even higher for
hispanic business owners they're in the
30s and that is devastating to the
community
and to the employees of those small
businesses who now no longer have a job
to go to and frankly in the african
american
community that small business number is
in the 40s
my question of secretary mnuchin is
minority-owned businesses have been the
hardest hit
in this covit 19 economic slowdown
do you agree with the assessment that
direct assistance
tailored assistance for those in
similarly situated
businesses would have a wide rippling
benefit to the economy
i i do senator absolutely and uh
you know i would say despite the the
success of project warp speed and the
fact that we will have
vaccines distributed in large mass the
problem is now as you said these small
businesses
can't wait two or three months so
i i would urge congress again to
reallocate
unused money and more money to ppp do a
set aside as we did last time
particularly for the underserved areas i
know that
you and senator warner and others have
worked on
a possibility of 10 billion dollars to
be invested into cdfis which could
lend a hundred billion dollars into un
underserved
communities so i i think there's a lot
that can be done and should be done very
quickly
uh thank you secretary mnuchin i would
say in addition to what we've already
done and what we can do and
if i'm correct secretary minister what
you're referring to is that the paycheck
protection program
still has unused resources sitting there
over a hundred billion dollars
that could be available for small
businesses right now
if congress would get their act together
our act together
and make those funds available to the
market that could have
a significant positive impact on the
employees of these small businesses who
today
simply cannot find the way forward with
my last few seconds
i think another opportunity that we have
before us
is to look at the paycheck protection
program forgiveness
of making it simple and it may take
congressional action for us to simplify
the process
uh do you see any uh ability in
from the administration's perspective to
streamline
and to simplify the process for banks
and therefore
making it easier for small businesses to
find
a little calm and a little comfort in
knowing that their small business loan
that was to be a grant
is actually going to become a grant i'll
be quite brief in responding but
i would say we've created three separate
forms so we've done everything we can on
administrative action including a
separate form
for 50 000 less but i would urge
congress
to make changes to the legislation to
allow for simpler
and again i would urge congress to out
reallocate the 140 billion dollars
that's sitting there
that can have an enormous impact for
small businesses in the ppp immediately
thank you uh secretary that can be done
today
we can do that today if we decide to do
so i'm supportive
of that concept thank you so much
senator menendez yeah thank you very
much
secretary mnuchin according to the uh
national bureau of economic research at
least
3.3 million small businesses have closed
441 000 of which are black owned small
businesses and six hundred and fifty
thousand
fifty seven thousand which are latino
owned businesses
1.1 million state and local employees
have lost their jobs according to the
bureau
of labor statistics uh you don't dispute
those figures is that fair to say
i i don't have them in front of me but i
have no reason to dispute them i assume
you're
quoting them accurately so how many more
small businesses do you project will
permanently shutter after you end the
cares act lending facilities
how many more state and local employees
will be laid off as a result of your
decision
again let me be clear mr senator mike my
decision is a legal decision not an
economic decision
congress can reauthorize this money if
you want to extend it but i think those
small businesses need grants they don't
need loans they can't
qualify for main street that's why main
street did only 10 billion dollars and
they need
ppp money well let me just say
that you cited earlier in response to i
believe
the chairman's questions uh section 4029
of the cares act as the reason that you
had to close
uh down these facilities what is wrong
with that
uh recitation is that this provision
applies to treasury authorities a
treasury's authority to invest
in new fed facilities and not the
ability of those facilities to make
loans to companies in the in the real
economy
so uh while i agree with you on grants
in the interim
we need to use every tool we
we have no one will be better off after
you
end the cares act facilities uh as we
enter
a a third wave of coven uh
i think uh any of these facilities is is
not
mandated by law uh it's uh
important as an economic backstop it
will have real and harmful consequences
on our recovery on our businesses on
american workers
um and you know during your previous
appearances before
the committee not a single member we
went through the records
even suggested that you should close the
facilities in fact most of us
on both sides of the aisle chairman
craigville senator brown senator tillis
myself and others
have been urging you to make changes to
the facilities
so that they could provide more relief
to businesses and state and local
governments as a matter of fact in
october in response to questions
from the congressional oversight
commission uh
you didn't say that the cares act
legally required you to end the
facilities
you just said you didn't think that they
were needed
so mr chairman i asked the treasury
department's responses to the
congressional oversight commission
dated october 16th to be entered into
the records
without objection so there is a choice
here
and unfortunately the choice you're
making is really consequential
to businesses to people to our uh
recovery
uh mr secretary last tuesday a treasury
department spokesperson
said that you plan to put the 429
billion dollars
you're withdrawing from the fed's
lending facilities into the
treasury's general fund is is that a
correct statement
again let me just first comment on the
first part i don't agree with your
reading
okay i believe that the section applied
to direct and indirect
and had you thought it applied otherwise
there would be a loophole and there
would be no point of having the date i
was never asked
about the december 31st date and i
always assumed that if congress wanted
to extend that they can
now as regards to the proceeds let me
direct you section
4003 which talks about the deposits of
proceeds again it is my intent to
completely follow
the law and the law requires the amounts
transferred
to go to the financing account and then
to repay any money
went to treasury so again we will
completely follow the law this is not
discretionary
again congress if you want to extend
this
bring back legislation which would
authorize you to do it
you can keep putting the the onus on
congress when in fact you have the
abilities uh let me read to you section
4027 of the cares act that provides
treasury with the appropriation of these
funds
quote on january on to january
1st 2026 any funds described in
paragraph one that are remaining shall
then be transferred to the general fund
of the treasury
it doesn't say by or no later than
january
of first 2026. so these funds being
moved
ultimately undermines i i hope uh
chairman powell
that you will commit to not return any
funds to the treasury until we are
assured that congress and the public
that those funds will remain
in the exchange stabilization fund as
required by the cares act
just for the record they don't go back
into the exchange stabilization fund as
i cited in the act
senator cotton
first off i want to join our colleagues
in thanking chairman crapo
uh for leading this committee so ably um
i do want to point out though
to paraphrase mark twain reports of his
demise may be greatly exaggerated he's
not going anywhere he's still gonna be a
senator he's simply gonna be chairing
the finance committee next year but
we've uh all appreciated his leadership
um the economy is recovering
more strongly than i think anyone
predicted in march and i think that's in
part because of the response of this
congress and the cares act at first
and then the way the trump
administration in particular
the department of the treasury and the
federal reserve has directed it so i
want to commend both of you gentlemen
on your stewardship over these last nine
months
now the economy could continue to
recover even more strongly in effect
and especially for those people who are
still struggling the most
the waitresses and the busboys the
bartenders the karate instructors the
music teachers
people who work in fields and industries
that have lots of
in-person close continual contact so
there's two things we can do
to help solve that problem immediately
one is to tell these democratic
governors and mayors to stop with their
irrational
lockdowns tell the governor of
california gavin newsom
not to lock down small mom-and-pop
restaurants while he goes off with all
of his lobbyist buddies
to eat at the french laundry one of the
world's most expensive and exclusive
restaurants paying 300
for caviar and truffles second
for congress to pass a new coronavirus
relief bill
we all have bipartisan agreement to
support those people who are still in
need
yet chuck schumer and nancy pelosi will
not relent on their three and a half
trillion dollar wish list they want to
hold up funding for small businesses
and for restaurants and for industries
like
airlines money to help schools reopen in
some states
or stay open as the case is in arkansas
so they can get things like
welfare checks for illegal immigrants or
they can override state voting laws or
let
violent villains out of prison things
that have nothing to do with the
coronavirus those are the two most
important things
we could do to help those who are still
struggling from this virus
get back to work until vaccines are
approved and widely distributed
what will not help what was not designed
to help
were the 13 three programs been so much
the point of discussion in this
conversation today
the thirteen three facilities have
achieved their purpose
the reason we wrote it and the reason
members of this committee helped draft
that language in march
was to stabilize credit markets to help
ensure the flow of credit to
fundamentally
credit worthy businesses and states
and cities it wasn't to subsidize
unsound or failing businesses that were
not
going to be able to succeed before china
unleashed this play on the world
it wasn't to bail out fiscally
irresponsible
mostly democratically led states and
cities who had mismanaged their finances
for years
or even decades it was to stabilize
credit markets
and i have to say it appears at the time
there was some bipartisan concern
that these funds could be misused i will
just quote from a few people
what they said at the time about
our treasury secretary joe biden
referred to these facilities as a 500
billion dollar slush fund
and a blank check ironically senator
brown
given the fact that he accused secretary
mnuchin today of sabotaging the recovery
or
intending to drive the economy off in a
ditch said at the time
the money 425 billion dollars the
secretary of the treasury can decide
is a slush fund or where to direct that
money
senator warren said that we're at 450
billion dollar slush fund that would go
to the secretary
of the treasury to help whoever he wants
and ironically given what senator
menendez just said to secretary mnuchin
this bill has a 425 billion dollar slush
fund with which basically
the secretary of the treasury can say i
like you you get this
i don't like you you get nothing
i guess the shoe may be on the other
foot now
and it seems like the democrats with the
hope of having a new secretary of the
treasury
and a new administration would like a
450 billion dollar slush fund
to reward politically favored
organizations like i don't know
abortion providers or marijuana
dispensaries
or maybe to bail out their partisan
allies in states and cities that have
mismanaged their finances
for years but
that's not what the law says
and that's the point that secretary
mnuchin has been making
all along if i'm not mistaken this is
not an economic decision
this is a legal decision this law was
designed
from the beginning to stabilize credit
markets
at the height of the uncertainty of this
pandemic in the spring and that's
exactly what it did
secretary mnuchin does not have legal
authority to keep these programs in
place
he took the right action and if our
democratic colleagues
want this money to be available then
they need
to work with us to pass new legislation
thank you
senator tester thank you acting chairman
tillis and i also want to thank
jones and mcsally for the opportunity to
serve with them on this committee and in
the united states senate
and i also want to thank uh chairman
crapo for his even-handedness and his
ability to
work with both sides of the aisle and
quite frankly unlike the last senator
actually bring people together and not
divide them so i appreciate
uh senator crapo in that regard um
look um i have the feeling we're
uh at a fulcrum here
where the economy still is in
very very difficult conditions and not
that what
senator toomey didn't say wasn't correct
six eight months ago was correct
but we're not out of the woods yet and
and and chairman powell
i have the feeling that if if we just
you know fold up our hands and walk away
that this economy uh not only might it
will
slip backwards over the next few months
that might be by design by some
serve in the united states senate uh or
in the administration
but it certainly isn't my goal and so
i would like chairman powell to
highlight the importance of
additional fiscal support for the
success of the economy moving forward
you talked about chairman powell you
talked about the folks out there who
continue to hurt and and i will tell you
that i think i think it's bigger than
just a ppp
program extension i think our healthcare
system
is uh quite frankly stressed to the max
in montana i'm not sure there's any beds
available for
this pandemic right now they're all full
um
and and i can tell you i think that's
the way it is in many parts of the state
so
when we talk about not locking down
let's go bury our heads in the sand and
assume that this pandemic hasn't even
happened
and it has no importance i got news for
you
my wife's been in treatment for cancer
and the cancer she will survive
if she gets this coven i'm not sure she
will
so i think we need to wake up in the
united states senate when it comes to
who's locking down
what and the reasons for it but that
aside
without any other comments i would just
say uh
chairman powell can you talk about the
importance of
addressing our healthcare business our
hospitality businesses
our working families that as you said
are
some are in really tough shape local
governments
by the way mismanaged local governments
give me a break
the united states senate under some of
the best economic times
ever borrowed a trillion dollars a year
and you accuse local government of
mismanagement
totally mackerel says it's harder for me
not to cuss
but and educational units uh so
chairman powell could you could you talk
a little bit about
what's really needed out there or this
economy may slip back do you see it the
same way i do
thank you senator um so i i think uh
i would put it a little bit in context
um you know we've we've done a lot
and we really appreciated the working
relationship we've had with treasury in
in the on the facilities
and uh thank them for the productive
work we've been able to do together
our own our our thinking is
that we would have left facilities in
place
to be backstops we don't question the
secretary's
decision about the cares act money
because that's entirely his decision to
make
but i think central banks generally
would would have done that
um in terms of of what more may be
needed
um we we're hearing a lot
from our discussions with people
throughout the federal reserve system
and across the country
about small businesses that may struggle
during this period of just the next few
months during the winter
with the spread of the virus high and it
is those it is those people who are
in uh public facing jobs in vulnerable
industries
and you know they see um they may see
what may be the light at the end of the
tunnel in the middle of next year as the
vaccines
come out and are widely distributed but
they may need more help to get to that
place and and so that's the way we're
looking at it we will continue to use
our tools to their fullest
extent and that will include 13-3
facilities if appropriate
if appropriate and if they meet the
legal requirements
but it may also include help to direct
help to businesses that really don't
need to borrow anymore as the secretary
was was noting
some of these businesses what they need
is is you know is
fiscal policy is is a grant to get them
through this last bit
of of uh of the pandemic rather than um
you know rather than borrowing more
through a federal reserve facility
uh yeah and i think i think we all agree
with that i think
in in in the end um
in the end if if nothing is done and i
don't think anybody on this committee
at least i hope not everybody on this
committee wants nothing to be done
but by the same token i don't think we
go into a job and do it
half-assed either um i think there are
plenty of
folks out there who are hurting big time
and i'm not just talking workers there's
workers that obviously are that have
worked looking for a job for so long
that they're off actually falling off
the unemployment roll
but small businesses uh whether we want
to
pound our chest or not but local
governments that have been put in a
situation because of reduced
income because of this pandemic or in a
tough situation
uh educational units because there are
many schools that are
doing dual uh distance learning and in
person need additional dollars um
do you do you see us sliding backwards
if we do nothing
or do you see the economy being static
for an extended period of time
yeah i think there's a risk i would
characterize these as risks the economy
has continued to perform
better than we expected it's been more
resilient to further outbreaks
than we've expected at the same time
this is a very large outbreak and
what we're hearing suggests that there
is a real risk of
small businesses and and uh people who
are on unemployment for extended period
periods and uh i think those are real
risks that should be taken into account
i want to thank both chairman powell and
secretary mnuchin for being here today i
appreciate your work
thank you senator rounds
thank you mr chairman um
first of all mr chairman i'd like to say
thank you to you for your leadership
uh and on the committee and i do
appreciate the fact that we've been able
to do some things on a bipartisan basis
and
uh that has a lot to do with with your
hard work
thank you i'd like to also thank i'd
also like to thank of
both of our guests here today uh uh
chairman powell uh and uh secretary
mnuchin i think you have
done very very good work under some very
trying circumstances
uh i'd like to begin my questioning
today with with secretary mnuchin
housing has been one of the bright spots
of our economy during the
pandemic and i want to make sure that we
do everything we can to continue
providing
the necessary support one of the
potential threats i see is ending the
conservatorship of the gses
oh while i agree in a perfect world that
conservatorship
should have been ended some time ago i
am concerned that if
recent conversations come to fruition
and fannie and freddie are prematurely
released from the fhfa's
control the strength we've seen in the
housing sector
could be called into question for
secretary mnuchin
in light of the pandemic what are your
recommendations with respect to the
timeline
for when conservatorship can be safely
unwound
well let me just say i i don't think
that they should be
let out from conservatorship without
appropriate capital there's obviously
different opportunities
to accumulate capital and raise capital
this is one of the areas that i will
continue
to try to work with this committee and
others i think there should be
housing reform i think that
the appropriate scenario is for these to
have real capital and ultimately them
be released thank you sir
a chairman powell follow-up the federal
reserve is the largest investor
in mortgage securities would you share
your thoughts
about the impact to the housing market
if an end to conservative ship
were to occur prior to the time in which
the pandemic impact
has been eased i
i would just uh echo the secretary's
point that um
i think we'd all i would certainly like
to see
the gses return to private hands over
time and the housing finance sector
and system standing on its own two feet
with a lot of private capital behind it
uh and um i think that so i think it's
something that
time needs to be taken on and and i
would applaud the new capital standards
that have been put in place and uh but
that capital still has to be raised and
i i do think um
it's something to uh to do carefully and
i know that's uh
that's consistent with what uh what the
secretary's thinking
you i appreciate also the flexibility
that our banking regulators have given
financial institutions
who have wanted to work with customers
experience with the covet
related hardships unfortunately not many
of us
thought the pandemic would last as long
as it has in
several sectors of the economy like the
airline industry
travel hospitality all still face
challenges what do we need to be doing
to support
the financial institutions who want to
continue working with customers
in these hard hit industries and i know
we talk about
targeted and specific assistance but
financial institutions have really been
right in the middle of this whole thing
and the expectation has been that that
we have allowed them flexibility i think
it'd be very helpful to hear
each of you your thoughts in this
particular issue and
in this case i'd ask chairman paul to go
first
so i think the most important thing is
that as the
economy recovers companies are
recovering
and the the faster the more they recover
and the faster they recover the
the smaller the losses will be i also
think it
we will continue to encourage banks to
work with their borrowers
and continue to keep in place the very
targeted
relief that we've provided which doesn't
undermine safety and soundness
in any way but that allows banks the
room to to do what they want to do which
is to serve their customers
so we wouldn't want supervision and
regulation
to undermine the process of working with
customers where it where it doesn't
implicate safety and soundness
secretary mnuchin i would just echo the
chairs comments and i think they've done
a very good job
across regulators and providing the
right flexibility
thank you and uh mr chairman i will
yield back
my final 15 seconds thank you
deeply appreciated senator warner let me
um
also echo what all my colleagues have
said thank you for your leadership on
this um
committee and let me thank you in
particular and secretary mnuchin so many
of us on both sides of the aisle for
your
help on putting together a plan to help
black and latino businesses that have
been particularly hard hit by coving
thank you um you may know that this
morning a bipartisan group of senators
um announced which i was proud to be
part of an emergency
relief framework that would help us get
through what i fear will be the worst
days of the pendant coming
i don't think the stakes should be
higher we all know that ui will start
running out for folks
the day after christmas we know we've
seen the food lines
across our country we know that small
businesses are on their last legs
they know that many state front-line
workers will soon have to be laid off
and literally we could have millions of
people put out of their homes
as early as middle of january i think
that's simply unacceptable and
my hope is uh that members of the
administration members of the congress
will sit down and figure out whether
this framework and alternative
uh can be that bridge and we get it done
before the holidays
it is this bridge and it's not a
long-term plan that i know that
secretary minucci was negotiating with
the speaker pelosi it's not
maybe even what some uh president biden
will want to do
but this this package which uh weighs in
at 908 billion dollars
does take care of ui it takes care of
health it takes care of student loan
assistance it takes care of small
business
with a focus on those cdfis it takes
care of
a broadband it takes care of food
insecurity
and at the end i'm going to make sure i
ask both of you
whether without knowing the details you
think generally this is a direction we
ought to head
let me also take one more minute because
this is something that
uh kratos
number of us on our side have come
together and that is a
in this package the 12 billion dollar
provision for new capital investments
from minority owned banks and cdfis
community development financial
institutions we know that black and
latino businesses have been particularly
hard hit by covet we've lost 440 000
black home businesses have shut their
doors that is a
generation of wealth accumulation that
has closed down we know that
40 percent of latino owned businesses
have closed their doors
um i heard for example from dr ann
people's constituent of mine who
five years ago opened up people's
pharmacy and diabetic center
in a low-income neighborhood in norfolk
um
copenhagen hit her business really hard
and
she said i treat folks the way i want
you to treat
me and when you ask and walk through the
door i want to receive compassion and
care that you deserve
that's exactly what they do her business
is on the brink of
shutting down and mr chairman i would
ask that her
article from the news story about his
people's business before turned into the
record
without objection and in my last two
minutes here i will i will
ask chairman powell and secretary
mnuchin
um two questions one while you've not
seen the details of the 908 billion
dollar plan that was bipartisan by
camera put out this morning framework
um do you think directionally this kind
of
bridge emergency relief is needed at
this point
uh chairman powell would you go first
i would of course defer to you and to
the secretary who have authority in this
area on the particulars of it but as
i've said i think
it sounds like you're hitting um a lot
of the a lot of the areas that could
definitely
benefit from help and and some of the
areas that are
these are areas that are going to be
experiencing uh a challenging winter so
but but i i can't really speak to the
particulars of the bill having not said
i appreciate that and again secretary
mnuchin i and i know you know that
while you've not seen any of this i know
you were negotiating on many of these
same particulars
again directionally uh without going
into particulars you think this kind of
effort is needed well let me first say
uh i did comment earlier
to senator scott and and i applaud the
work that you've done
on the cdfi program so whether it's 10
or 12 billion i very much support that
that could
create 100 billion of lending quickly uh
i look forward to
reviewing with you the the overall
passion i do think that more fiscal
response is needed
i think what's more important is what we
can pass
quickly on a bipartisan basis to target
the most difficult parts of of the
economy uh
and hopefully uh that will be needed and
done
quickly so i look forward to following
up with you i missed the press
conference because i'm
here testifying i understand i i promise
you we will share that
with you immediately mr chairman i just
want to appeal to all my colleagues
um this is our best uh effort at a
framework i hope everyone will give it a
reasonable review
and uh again appreciate your leadership
on this committee thank you
thank you mark most of our members are
off voting right now but i understand
that senator warren
is with us i am go ahead please
thank you very much mr chairman so today
more people are getting sick from the
coronavirus that in
any other time during the pandemic and
on top of that
many people uh the help that many people
have relied on is about to disappear
so the day after christmas 12 million
workers will lose unemployment benefits
that same week
secretary mnuchin will be shutting down
the federal reserve programs that are
designed to help the economy
so chair powell you have been clear
about the need for more physical support
to help families and businesses
get through this crisis so let me ask
you specifically about help to
individuals
that puts more money in their pockets
during an economic crisis this is kind
of
economic stimulus 101. if individuals
have a bit more
cash to spend every month that helps
them but it also helps the economy right
yes yeah okay so there are two ways to
get more money into people's pockets
the first is providing payments like
stimulus checks or unemployment
insurance
which i strongly support the second is
by canceling the debts that people owe
so they can spend that money elsewhere
the largest category of household debt
other than mortgages is student loans
and most of that debt
is owed directly to the federal
government now right now those
debt payments are paused but the clock
is running out
on new year's day the median borrower
will have to restart
paying more than 200 a month to the
federal government
that's at a time when our economy needs
people to be able to spend
more money not less so mr chairman
you've said
in testimony before congress that you
think that
rising student debt is quote
the main concern when looking at the
overall household debt
picture you've also said quote it's been
rising fast
and is now large there is increasing
evidence that shows that students who
can't pay that debt
have difficulty having normal economic
lives and buying homes
and things like that end quote mr
chairman would you agree
that high levels of student debt will
have a negative impact
on our economic recovery if millions of
households
have to reduce spending in order to make
debt payments
so uh others and and i have been calling
out the
rising student debt for some years now
particularly since we've singled it out
for
not being able to be forgiven and
forgiven and insolvency
among all different kinds of debt so
that's a longer term problem
in terms of what appropriate relief it
would would be
what what relief would be appropriate
here in the current situation i would
i would uh have to defer to those who
have authority to make that decision
well i'm not asking you about what the
the
question is about what congress should
do i'm asking the question
about what it does to the economy if
people who
instead of spending that money in the
economy are spending that money
by sending money back to the federal
government on their student loan
payments
that is a problem for the economy is it
not
certainly people who are weighed down by
debt in a situation like this where they
may be unemployed
uh where unemployment is very high among
for example low-wage workers
that can weigh on economic activity yes
fair enough but i think we started with
uh uh with economic stimulus 101 200
bucks is 200 bucks
that could be spent in the economy now
mr chairman you've also noted that
student loan debt
has another impact on a struggling
economy and that is that student loan
debt makes it harder for people
to qualify for mortgages to buy homes to
start small businesses
you've noted that those things drag our
economy down
do you still feel that way yeah so
i think over data are showing that over
longer periods of time people who
take on student debt in an effort to
make their lives better
and brighter and if that doesn't work
out that way they drag that debt down
through their economic lives and it can
get in the way of
their credit history of course and their
ability to own a home and
in their whole economic life for for
many years
right and then that has an overall
impact on the economy
in terms of home sales or in terms of
business startups is that right
yes in effect those people are unable to
participate
perhaps in the economy to the full
extent that they might be able to which
would weigh on the economy
so thank you mr chairman you know i know
you've said you don't know how you could
be clearer
on pushing congress to act on more
physical stimulus and i agree entirely
with you on that
but most types of economic stimulus are
pretty much impossible when the
republicans in congress
refuse to take action aid to state and
local governments unemployment benefits
checks for families right now
republicans are blocking help on all of
these
but student loan debt is different all
on his own
president-elect biden will have the
ability to administratively
cancel billions of dollars in student
loan debt
using the authority that congress has
already given to the secretary of
education
this is the single most effective
economic stimulus
that is available through executive
action
and as you've noted in the past research
shows that
canceling student loan debt would boost
gdp
create jobs reduce unemployment jump
start small business formation
support the housing market promote job
and
economic uh and geopolitical uh
mobility and increase the annual incomes
of borrowers by about four thousand
dollars
so it would also help close the racial
wealth gap
it is time to act thank you very much
thank you mr chairman
thank you and next will be senator
schatz
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
secretary mnuchin and chair powell uh
for participating in this hearing and
for your uh really
uh extraordinary efforts during this
difficult time
our first question is for for secretary
mnuchin uh where are we with
negotiations you've been
uh lead negotiator on behalf of the
administration when we were successful
and lead negotiator when we were not as
successful and i just want to get a
sense for the public
and for the whole congress so that we're
not just reading this
on politico uh where we are with respect
to coronavirus relief whether
the idea is to pass a stand-alone
package from your perspective
for something to ride on the omnibus and
what would your priorities be
i had a conversation yesterday afternoon
as well as this morning a follow-up
conversation
with mitch mcconnell kevin mccarthy
myself and mark meadows
i spoke to the president this morning
and updated him
we all believe that there should be
targeted
fiscal response i would say that my
motivation
in the fed facilities was not political
as i said it was purely legal
but uh those funds can be reallocated
the ppp money can be reallocated
i would say things like ppp and
uh unemployment that running are running
out are high on the list i'll be
speaking to
speaker pelosi this afternoon about
the government funding we obviously not
intended for
to be an icr be another signed the
two-year cap
deal wanted to get funded on i'm sure i
will speak to her about cares
funding as well so we support targeted
quick relief okay and i'll just
editorialize for about 30 seconds here
you know the election is over and lame
ducks are for
doing necessary things that we were
fighting about
that's what a laden duck is for and
especially during a pandemic
that's what a lame duck is for and so we
all need to put our weapons down
and i applaud the efforts of senators uh
warner and collins and coons and others
because we really need
uh to deliver relief um and especially
because we need to recognize that if we
can't get something done
during a lame duck during a pandemic
that says something about all of us and
our unwillingness
to find a middle ground a separate topic
for chair powell i am
really encouraged to see the fed discuss
climate risks in their semi-annual
report on financial stability
you know you and i have had several
exchanges in the past few years about
the financial system's vulnerability
to climate shocks and i'm really pleased
to see the fed address this issue
head-on
the report calls for increased
transparency through improved
measurement and disclosure and to
improve
the pricing of climate risks so the
question i have for you is what
specifically should companies be
disclosing
to enable the accurate pricing of
climate risks
you know we of course corporate
disclosure is really something that we
don't uh have
responsibility for i think what we're
what we're talking about
is sort of a general uh idea at this
stage
it's an early uh stage in trying to
understand the implications of climate
change for financial stability and
thank you for calling out our box i
thought that the box we put in our
financial stability report did a good
job of
of laying out the connections that we do
see but i think we're a long way from
understanding really what that means i
think the public will expect
that we do figure out what are the
implications of climate change
for financial stability and that we do
put policies in place
some of that will be through disclosure
and some of it will be through
uh you know many other channels so the
fed staff is uh
actively conducting research on
climate-related financial risk
what kinds of tools are you developing
and what kind of data sets do you need
to measure that risk
well i mean again it's early to be
talking about um
really there's as you pointed out
there's a great deal of research going
on
in the economics community and and you
know we have the
probably the largest economic staff
certainly in the united states
one of the largest in the world and
there are people working on
on climate change and the implications
of climate change for the economy and
financial for financial stability
and um it's a little early to say
exactly
what uh what those tools will do and i i
guess i would i ought to start by saying
that
the broad response to climate change on
on the part of society really needs to
be set
by elected representatives that's you uh
we we see implications of climate change
for the job that you've given us and
that's that's what we're working on is
just that aspect of it
the broader aspect of it really is for
elected representatives
absolutely and chairman i agree with you
um risk is risk
um you are charged at least partly with
measuring the risk
in the in the financial system
you are not charged with solving climate
change that's the policy making part of
the government
but it is important that you fulfill
your statutory mandate to make sure that
risk
is measured accurately and one final
thought here
i'm not sure it's so much that it's
early i think it's more that this stuff
is hard and i can see that this stuff is
difficult
that we want to develop common platforms
we want to develop
common tools and data sets so that we do
this intelligently and responsibly
but it is not early it is just that this
stuff is difficult to do
and we want to give you the space to do
it right but uh we can't take several
years to develop these tools and data
sets
thank you thank you senator kennedy
thank you mr chairman uh chairman powell
has the federal reserve
done a state by state analysis
of how much money state governments have
received
from congress uh to bolster their
economy
and how much of that money they have
left to spend
senator i'm i'm confident somewhere in
uh somewhere in the
federal reserve system that information
does exist i don't i don't have it close
to hand though
what does that information show
honestly i wouldn't be able to i'd have
to get the information in front of me to
be able to answer that
then how do you know state governments
need more money
well i didn't say that today uh that
they did need more money
um but i would i would say uh we do know
that at the aggregate level i mean i can
give you some
some some data that i i believe is true
and that is that
um states that are that have
particularly high
um sort of tourism
uh as part of their economy are are
feeling this
significantly and they've got much lower
tax revenue so they're feeling that
states that that don't really have
exposure to travel and leisure
uh may not have had much of an effect at
all so it does vary quite a bit but
there are states i think florida
for example has i read has
lost something like 11 of its of its
revenue overall
that i can't fact check that in real
time here but that's the statistic that
i saw so i think it varies a lot state
to state
um on november 16th
the wall street journal reported that
california
recently reported that its tax revenue
for this fiscal
year is running 19
above projections
do you disagree with that i don't have
any reason to no
in the same analysis the journal
reported that personal income tax
revenue
in october in california was 1 billion
or 16 percent higher than the previous
october
and sales taxes were up 9.2 percent
is that consistent with the fed's
information
i honestly don't i haven't seen any
information at the fed
as i mentioned i i think the the bigger
fact is
that state and local government revenues
tax revenues
have been less affected so far than we
thought they would and
there's a lot of research on why that
might be
nonetheless state and local governments
have laid off more than a million people
and some states are are feeling this the
ones that are more exposed to
to travel and leisure the travel legion
industry for example are are actually
really feeling
that pinch uh the federal reserve
uh excuse me the wall street journal on
november 16th
also reported that uh in new york state
overall tax revenue was up 4.3 percent
in september compared to september 2019
a large part of the reason for that is
that uh
new york state taxes unemployment
benefits
do you have any reason to disagree with
that
no sir okay
the journal also reported that personal
income tax revenue
in connecticut increased 2.9 percent in
september
from the previous year and in the fiscal
year this started
in july income tax receipts
in connecticut are running 0.3
ahead of last year and sales tax revenue
is up
5.3 do you know if that's accurate or
not
i don't okay
do you believe
that congress should appropriate
money to states and allow those states
to use that money to uh
to support their pension systems
i think that's a that's a question for
you sir
well i'm asking you though mr chairman
you've
you've been pretty vocal about about and
i'm not being critical i appreciate the
advice
but about the need to pass another
coronavirus bill
do you think we should allow the states
to use the money
to shore up their retirement their
retirement systems
i i think states provide critical
services i think at least some of them
have had significant hits to revenue
i think they've laid off more than a
million people they're very big
employers something like
i mean one one of the largest employers
in the economy so i think it's an area
that that's i've always said it's an
area where i think it's worth
an area don't don't don't you think
that i'm sure you would agree with this
don't you think though
before we appropriate more money
we should actually base the decision on
empirical data
like how much have we given each state
how much have the states uh
spent how much they just uh
how much of that money do they have
still just sitting there don't you think
we ought to
auto approach it as opposed to just
using anecdotal evidence
certainly i wouldn't recommend you use
anecdotal evidence but really these
questions are way off my range
i uh you know we we don't give we don't
have views or express views on really
specific
fiscal questions try to stay at a high
level thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
van hollen
uh thank you um thank you mr chairman
and uh
thank you chairman powell secretary
mnuchin
uh for your testimony and uh listening
to
both of you there's clearly agreement uh
that
uh we need more fiscal relief um
mr chairman uh you said on october 6
that quote too little support would lead
to a weak recovery creating
unnecessary hardship for households
and businesses and more recently
as the cases from the pandemic have
accelerated uh you've said uh
there hasn't been a bigger need for
it in a long time meaning fiscal relief
and
uh president trump um in october
uh tweeted out uh go big or go home
to congress and just picking up on
senator schatz's comments and others
um we do need to get this done we cannot
go home um before
the end of december without addressing
uh the urgent needs and the pain that
american households and small businesses
are are facing so as chairman powell
first to you i i assume you agree today
with the statements you've made
previously about the urgent need
uh for substantial uh fiscal relief
well let me see when i when i said this
is the
the most urgent need i was talking about
the whole pandemic i was talking about
you know the need for the cares act and
not i wasn't trying to speak about
the need for another full cares act at
that point in time that that's what i
believe i was referring to it is a
couple of months ago
um but yes i i my view really hasn't
changed i think that the
uh the risk of overdoing it
is less than the risk of underdoing it
that is the record of of pandemics and
crises
there you know you always think you're
people are always worried about doing
too much and you look back in hindsight
and you say well
we didn't do too much we might have done
we might have done a little more and
done a little sooner
i think we tried to live with that
lesson this time as as
uh with the cares act and with the
things that the fed did and other parts
of government we really did act
aggressively so
i would just say that we've come a long
way the cares act did a tremendous
amount of good
we we can see what may be the light at
the end of the tunnel with the vaccines
and i just would want us we at the fed
will keep at it until we're really done
and i think that some fiscal support now
would really would really help move the
economy along as well
at least to guard against those downside
risks we've been talking about smaller
businesses
households and others who are directly
affected
well i i agree and with respect to state
and local governments i was
listening to your discussion with
senator kennedy and i would say
one million people who've lost their
jobs is not anecdotal
uh that is real as you pointed out those
are people who
no longer have an income um and
therefore
are relying on a safety net until we get
everybody back to work
uh secretary mnuchin um again i
quoted president trump uh back in
october saying to congress go big or go
home
um just recently he tweeted again
uh go big and be focused
um make it big and focused um so
do you share the presence view that we
continue to need to go big
on fiscal relief i do believe we need
more fiscal relief and i think there's
more work to be done as i said in my
testimony i think fortunately the cares
act has worked and the numbers are
better than they were
two months ago but i urge congress to
pass something
quickly to make sure we get something
done
uh in in this session i i couldn't agree
with you more and
i know that you were engaged for a
period of time with speaker pelosi and
others
um what what was the trump
administration prepared to do in terms
of its top-line number at that time
uh because uh the chief of staff the
president was quoted as
uh saying somewhere around 1.2
uh trillion trillion dollars or more is
that
is that accurate well i think as you
know we made
lots of proposals along the way there
were different proposals and different
components and as i said earlier
i i spoke to leader
mcconnell and and mccarthy and meadows
this morning and the president
and we will continue to work with
congress to try to get something done
quickly
but mr secretary you would agree it
would be a mistake to allow the
emergency pandemic unemployment
insurance to expire at the end of the
month right
i do believe that's one of the areas i
think there needs to be some technical
fixes but i
i do support extending it i also
absolutely support the unspent money and
the ppp
uh being authorized to be used
immediately
and you also supported i know so the
president did
funding for some state local government
relief i can tell you
i had a conversation this morning with
the general manager of the washington
metro transit system
you can read on the front page of the
you know washington post metro
section today that they're going to lay
off 1200 people
uh in december and that their budget for
next year
if they don't get any more relief
contemplates another
over 2000 uh people so
i i hope we will all recognize that
we've got to do
something there seems to be a lot of
running room between the two positions
that have been outlined
and i just think it would be shameful um
if the
congress goes home and the
administration
if we're not able to do this uh before
the end of the month so thank you mr
chairman
thank you senator jones
thank you mr chairman um and thank you
to both of our witnesses
for your service secretary mnuchin uh
you and i haven't had as much
personal interaction but i want to tell
you how much i appreciate
your service in some difficult times
over the last two or three years
um chairman powell um thank you
very much for uh allowing me to get to
know you
uh for the work we had i so much
appreciated the fact that even though
your
nomination was going to sail through the
united states senate you still made a
point
of coming to visit with me uh as soon as
i got sworn in in january
of 2018 uh to get to know me and to
understand
the office and my work on the banking
committee so thank you for that
um i'd like to kind of revisit something
that i have talked about
on many occasions and that's the racial
inequalities that we
witness in this country um
as the nation kind of grapples with the
racial inequality we've seen
the federal reserve's recent survey of
consumer finance kind of caught my eye
highlights long-standing substantial
wealth disparities between families
in different racial and ethnic groups
the typical white family has
eight times the wealth eight times the
wealth of the typical black family and
five times the wealth
of the typical hispanic family rafael
bostic
president of the federal reserve bank of
atlanta recently published a paper
arguing that the country's racial
economic gaps were cemented
over centuries and called on the fed to
reduce racial inequalities and bring
about a more inclusive economy
and let me say that very quickly that uh
i know coming from a state
um of the old confederacy that most
people think that some of this
is just based on the state jim crow laws
of years past
but in fact we all know that this is not
just
a a southern problem it is not just a
jim crow problem
uh those policies have been cemented
by policies of the federal government uh
laws passed by this congress
uh maybe giving some accommodation to
white southern uh
segregationists who were in the house
and the senate at the time
but laws of housing uh health care even
the gi bill
really kind of cemented uh in the
inequalities that have lasted now
for for decades so initially to you
chairman powell as we go forward i don't
want to look back right now i want to
look
forward because as we're coming out of
this pandemic we've got some real
opportunities i believe
to address these inequalities in health
care and the economy
in so many areas so what can the fed do
as we come out of this economy what
strategies would you recommend
to kind of address the inequality we see
in the economy whether it's minority
businesses or individuals
so these are long-standing inequalities
over a very long period of time and uh
there's a real concern that that we have
at the fed that that the pandemic will
make that worse because of course
minorities are
much over resent represented in these
uh service industry jobs which that were
so heavily affected by the pandemic
so there's a concern that things will
get worse uh and i'm
you know the last couple of years were
very encouraging because as the
as the longest expansion in our recorded
history continued
we actually saw the racial unemployment
gap
uh diminishing to its lowest level since
we began measuring it
and so it's really disappointing to see
to see that so what can we do going
forward
um you know the most important thing we
can do with the fed i think
is to um is to take seriously
the job of achieving maximum employment
and we've now
um we've now changed our operating
framework to
acknowledge that maximum employment is a
broad and inclusive goal and by that we
me
we mean that we're going to look uh at
various different measures
of uh of of labor market
uh conditions including including
minority unemployment rates
frankly minority participation labor
force petition rates and wages and
things like that we're going to look at
all of those things as we try to achieve
our maximum employment goal
the last thing i'll say is i think we
also enforce fair lending laws in our in
our
division of consumer community affairs
well we need to we need to continue to
do that rigorously
ultimately though we will do whatever we
can with our tools but
uh but really it's going to take a
broader uh
a broader attack on these problems than
than just the fed alone can uh
can mount thank you mr chairman
secretary mnuchin i got just a few
minutes left
any advice that you would give a few
seconds left actually
any advice that you would give to the
incoming administration or the incoming
congress
about how to address these from an
economic standpoint
well as i've mentioned earlier i do
think the cdfi
investments are something that can be
done quickly that will
particularly help minority and
underserved communities
all right thank you mr secretary mr
chairman if you would bear with me just
a couple more seconds i wanted to
express my appreciation to you and the
ranking member and to all the members on
the committee
for the work that we've had together
over the last three years
it's been remarkable to work with you to
watch the two of you work
but also the work that i've done with
other members on the committee on both
sides of the aisle
it has been an honor and a privilege to
work with the entire committee
uh i hope that as you mr chairman move
over
to another committee and uh assume
additional duties that
uh chairman toomey or ranking member to
me as the case may be we don't know yet
uh will carry on the work uh of this
committee
i have really enjoyed my time with you
over the last three years
so thank you both very much thank you
senator jones
senator tillis thank you mr chairman i
i want to thank both senator mcsally
and senator mcsally and senator jones
for their service on this committee
there were serious legislators and had
the opportunity to work with both of
them i also want to thank you for your
leadership you'll leave it in good hands
but i'm going to miss you as her chair
gentlemen thank you for being here i am
as i heard the discussions had to go
vote i'm sorry i wasn't here for the
the whole of the the hearing but uh i
remember
vividly back in march when we were
negotiating that we i say with the
senator
or senator secretary mnuchin and members
of the senate working together
we we had a underlying set of
assumptions some that proved to be true
some didn't
we knew we needed to do something big
bold and fast
and we came up with the cares act and i
think the paycheck protection program
saved a lot of jobs i also think the
main street lending facility was a
necessary facility even though at the
time very few of us thought that it
would be fully subscribed
and it's proven to be true we also made
certain assumptions about how long this
virus was going to impact
the economic base i mean there were a
lot of people thinking 90 days six
months
on the outside maybe the end of the year
which was the basis for
uh the date that uh secretary mnuchin
mentioned well things have changed
and i for one think that we do have to
provide a bridge to what should be
a trending positive environment maybe
sometime in the second half of next year
if we make certain assumptions about the
manufacturing distribution of the
vaccine that i think can be valid with
the historic approval
of two vaccines in uh in less than a
year
but uh secretary mnuchin you know i have
to
remind everybody of what you've said you
have said that you think that these
states are important and that congress
needs to act but you've also in the same
breath said that we need hundreds of
billions dollars
more and the paycheck protection program
to provide that bridge
that stabilization is that your basis
for that that we just need to cover that
window of opportunity probably through
the second half of next year
that that is correct maybe the first
quarter or
second quarter yeah um and then uh and
chairman powell i i think you feel the
same way i don't think that we're
necessarily talking about somebody
something on the scale of either the
first cares act or the heroes act
but something that does provide some of
the fundamentals for the businesses and
i think that they do need to be grants
not loans
but do you agree with that window that
we we really need to provide the bridge
based on the information we have today i
think the bridge
is exactly the right way to think about
it i don't have i won't
have a view on exactly how much that
needs to be but that's the way we we can
see that we can see the end we just need
to make sure we get there
yeah one thing and chairman powell this
may be for you of the
10 million jobs that uh are still
outstanding has there been
any analysis on uh the length of time
that they're likely we've got in north
carolina we have about 19 000
restaurants 4 000 of them have closed
permanently
so there's a structural element of
unemployment where even when the economy
comes raging back the job creators are
not going to come back
in time to see that pickup save in the
second half so do we have any
uh analysis on the amount of
unemployment
that if we provide additional
stabilization funds
if if we see the trending in the right
direction with the vaccine what what is
our structural deficit for that
remaining
unemployment our the how much of that is
structural long-term versus likely to
bounce back as the economy bounces back
because the jobs are there
as the business reopens and expands
that that really is the big question
we've been asking ourselves and and you
have to make a lot of assumptions to
have an answer about that
it really is what does the post pandemic
economy look like
and i think the faster we the faster we
get there
the sooner the vaccines arrive etc then
the smaller that number of people who
are structurally unemployed will be
and there are various numbers we'll be
happy to share
something with you with your office if
you'd like yeah
in my uh my closing time number one i
just want to thank you all for the
extraordinary leadership and the job i
want to thank the banking industry
for actually being a partner that helped
us make the paycheck protection program
a success
i believe that we have to look at
programs to take a look at the first and
last out
industries we've talked about a lot of
them restaurants live performances
motor coaches transportation
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done but i don't think
anyone can rightfully criticize or
suggest suggested the cares act hasn't
been anything short of the
mvp for stabilizing the economy when we
had the crisis
and you guys were two people on the team
that made it uh
made it successful i don't believe that
we should be asking secretary
mnuchin to do congress's job if congress
is serious about funding paycheck
protection if they're serious about
stabilizing the economy
then get serious about passing a
follow-up to the cares act
thank you mr chair
and now i guess i'm mr chair uh
senator cortez masto
senator smith thank you mr chair
and hello everyone first i just want to
say it does my heart good to see my
colleague senator doug jones who i'm
used to sitting next to on the banking
committee
um and i just want to thank you so much
for your service
and we are going to miss you and thanks
also of course to
senator mcsally and um i know that the
chair isn't here uh
but i want to also thank chair crapo for
his leadership he has been nothing but
welcoming to me
and um i think um though as
chair as ranking member brown said we
don't always agree i
always feel that there is a way for us
to work together which is so important
i want to just start by saying i want to
add my voice to
the many voices on this committee today
who said that it's really important that
we get something done
to um help families and small businesses
that have been really struggling through
this pandemic you know
we've got to get something done and i
also agree that we shouldn't make
perfect be the enemy of the good here
that is what i am hearing
um in minnesota and i have to say i have
never worked any place where i heard
more people talking more loudly about
the need for action with less action
happening
i haven't had a chance to see what our
colleagues bipartisan group have put
together
i get this morning but i'm encouraged by
that and hope that that will take us
somewhere
and i might ask my republican colleagues
to bring this up with senator mcconnell
when you all have lunch together
um in a couple of minutes because um
there's a great need for action here
i wanna um actually uh uh pivot to
something and and
have a little bit of a dialogue with you
uh chair powell about this you have used
i think very appropriately
this metaphor of how we need to build a
bridge to a post
pandemic recovery you point out that
our economy has been responding better
than we expected but we still
have a really really long way to go and
um you know we also know that we are
seeing
long-term trends in inequality which
make it harder and harder to generate
the
economic activity the spending that is
going to drive growth
in the long term and that is what we see
because of raising
long-term interest and inequality that
are holding back spending for
families of color minority businesses of
color this is something several of my
colleagues have brought up today
so uh chair powell could you just uh
talk a little bit about this
and i'm especially interested in
using your bridge analogy uh you know
what are the risks of not
building this bridge what happens if we
don't uh take this action right now and
and the long-term impacts of this
growing inequality on our
economy a post-pandemic
thank you senator smith so um these
disparate economic outcomes across
racial and other lines are a
long-standing feature
of our economy they've been with us for
a very long time
and um there there is a great risk that
the pandemic is making them worse
because uh
the the people who are most affected by
the job losses uh were people in
relatively low paying parts of the
service industry that happens to skew
more to minorities and to women
and so if there's a real concern that
that that uh
if we don't act as quickly as possible
to
support those people get them back to
work get the economy up and running as
much as possible
that will leave behind a more unequal
situation which is
which is tragic because we actually had
been making good progress on these
issues
for the last few years as the very long
expansion
longest in our recorded history went on
we started to see
the gains go more to people at the lower
end of the income spectrum we saw we saw
racial
income gaps declining racial gaps in
labor force participation and
unemployment
declining we saw some very constructive
things but
waiting for the eighth or ninth year of
an expansion is not a is not a perfect
strategy so
i think um there really is there is an
issue of wanting to
do as much as we can to avoid uh
exacerbating these long-standing
differences and get back to a strong
economy where we can start making
progress again which is what we were
doing just back in february
well and you know as the fed chair and
as the fed you have the dual mission of
um
low unemployment and um you know uh
managing inflation hitting inflation
target rates
what if the fed in this need to spur uh
uh job growth and we see that there
hasn't been a big worry about inflation
in the long term what if the fed were to
lower
its um its target for employment you
know lower to three or even under three
percent
uh how what impact might that have on
addressing long-term
needs for um addressing inequality so
actually
we've made a change in our operating
framework which i think addresses that
directly
and that is um well we're going to have
an estimate of the natural rate of
unemployment
uh we're not going to act on that even
if unemployment goes below that
unless we see inflation or some other
problematic thing that seems to be
linked to where our rates are so
we're nev we're not and we're not going
to preemptively raise rates until we see
actual inflation now uh as a consequence
of low unemployment
and i think that's a lesson that we
learned during the last expansion when
we saw
very low 50-year lows in unemployment
with
really no and very high participation
really a strong
a strong labor market as we've seen in
in my lifetime
without inflation acting in in a way
that was concerning
thank you chair pal thank you mr chair
and i also want to extend my thanks to
secretary mnuchin for his service
thanks very much everyone thank you
senator cramer
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
to the to the two witnesses of course
for being here
um and let me just also say uh
congratulations
to to chairman krapon a wonderful two
years as chairman and he's been you've
been great to me
and to the whole committee and really
really appreciate your approach
and um also uh thank you
to um senator mcsally senator jones we
will miss
you both and we're very grateful for
your service now
you shouldn't surprise anybody that the
issue of on my mind the one that i
pretty much wake up thinking about every
day
i'm wondering how we're ever going to
tackle it of course is um
with the cares act is ppp forgiveness
and secretary mnuchin
i just want to address a couple things
directly to you you know of course that
senator menendez and i along with
senator tillis and
senator cinema and about 28 of our
closest friends and allies
from both political parties have
introduced that uh
forgiveness bill senate 4117
takes all the loans at 150 000 less
one-page attestation
um and and we those would be forgiven
that those those 150 000 unless loans
make up
like i said 85 of the total loans but 26
only 26 of the dollar amount
and both of you now both both the
chairman paul and secretary mnuchin have
said during
this hearing that what businesses need
are not loans
but they need grants well forgiveness
was a major component
of our bill and once again in my view
congress did what it often does and it
doesn't prescribe enough of a solution
that allows the bureaucracy which i fear
more than the devil himself frankly
um to come up with their own rules and
regulations are always aimed
at um cya
no understanding of how a business
operates
or how it keeps employees but when we
passed ppp
as you'll recall it was designed to
largely be
forgiven it was designed to make keep
people on a payroll so they avoided
the unemployment rolls we encouraged
almost
forced small lenders and small borrowers
use
the program i've talked to literally
hundreds multiple times
hundreds of community banks consumer
banks large banks
credit unions even farm credit services
about ppp and why it needs to be
utilized
and yet here we are still waiting for
another package
it is my hope desire conviction to work
my tail off
to prescribe a solution to this but in
the meantime
mr secretary i've been very disappointed
in sba's response
they seem to use like the bureaucracy
always does use their discretion to the
advantage of the government
not to the advantage of the small
business let me give you just some
specific examples
that i've heard from my constituents i'm
going to give you one
borrower example small business pretty
typical i think
here's what they wrote to me senator
kramer
please help that's the opening line with
congress
not passing a new stimulus it leaves
many small businesses in the bind the
problem is as we go to our bank and ask
for
an uh operating loan they tell us not
until you get your ppp forgiveness
now why haven't they gotten it you know
we've been pretty instructive on this
um the bank says until we receive notice
from sba that our original ppp
loan has been forgiven they aren't going
to give us the money
here's how slowly they are work they're
working on this particular loan this is
a loan of just
right at about a hundred thousand
dollars
they have um moved so slow
that they needed some pressure from us
so we applied that pressure and here's
what it took
it took nine weeks nine weeks
mr secretary to forgive a one hundred
thousand dollar
loan where the program was designed for
it to be forgiven
this is a small motel hotel operation in
bismarck
nine weeks and guess what it took really
nine weeks in one day because the day
that we made the call to inquire
at sba they finally forgave the loan now
this is one this is just one example out
of
hundreds maybe even thousands of them
here's one from a lender before i let
you answer um
here's a lender says just reaching out
as fyi
sba has requested additional
documentation on five
percent of the loans ranging from 3
700 to 134 thousand it's an
average of thirty three thousand dollars
per loan it's a waste of time
so the bureaucracy again always does
what the bureaucracy is going to do
mr secretary this is very disappointing
this is very disappointing to people
who didn't even want to take photos they
could have they could have laid all of
these people out they could have gotten
that
very generous unemployment extension
program but they
trusted us and and sba did what we
just know the very options i was going
to do they've extended the time they've
asked for more documentation they put
more demands on them
the cost the cost to comply is now two
thousand dollars per borrower
and it amounts to billions of dollars i
can obviously my time is up i'd love to
hear more from you i've got lots more to
say about it
but we've got to do better than this mr
secretary i
agree with you we need to do better and
we support uh
legislation to help forgiveness but in
the meantime use your discretion
please use the the flexibility that the
agency has and
tell the bureaucracy to stop being such
a bureaucracy there's a big
disconnect between the bureaucrat and
and the business and billionaires in the
business we need
small businesses to thrive thank you
senator cortez masto
thank you gentlemen thank you it's great
to see you again so appreciate you being
here let me just
jump right into it as you know i i talk
to you about this all the time
come from nevada the hospitality and
leisure industry has been so
hard hit nevada's unemployment rate now
is more than 12 percent
uh we know that more than 175 000 people
continue to claim unemployment insurance
just the statistics from the american
hotel and lodging association
that that nearly 70 percent of hotels
may close by the end of
this year if they do not receive
additional
government funding and i will tell you
in las vegas
and reno employment in our hospitality
and leisure sector is down
nearly 25 and 14 respectively
so let me start there with both of you
um
secretary mnuchin what is the
administration and or what are you
advocating moving forward that we should
do to address
the the really the impact that we are
seeing on our leisure and hospitality
industry
well uh specifically and i agree with
you that this industry has been
devastated i believe that the ppp could
immediately help people i think that the
airlines have
also been devastated so we support
additional relief for the airlines but
hotels uh small businesses
uh entertainment all of these companies
could access the
the ppp well let me jump back there
because when i talk about hospitality
and leisure i'm talking about
restaurants i'm talking about live
events
uh and if they're at assessing the ppp
they're not looking for loans
and i think you've said it earlier it's
not the loans that help it's the grants
isn't that correct shouldn't we be
looking at providing them more
opportunities for for grants than than
loans that they have to pay back well
the ppp if it's used correctly
is a grant so it's a loan that should
get forgiven
uh without the bureaucracy but yes the
ppp
is effectively a grant and that's what
they need not more
loans yeah effectively it is but as
we've heard
there's challenges with it and ensuring
and i think
the confusion even for these businesses
is whether that will turn
from a loan into a grant is still
questionable for many of them and that's
why we're seeing the concerns that we
see for so many not even applying
um let me um ask uh chairman powell
i know you and i have had this
conversation again
do you believe that the hospitality and
leisure industry needs another stimulus
package like a comprehensive package for
relief
to sustain this industry i would agree
that the industry has really been
devastated
and the two things it needs is for the
pandemic to be over which
which we really can't do and it needs
grants which we also can't do our
our loan programs are really not for you
can't over
generalize but for most people in that
most businesses in that industry
really what they need is more fiscal
support that's right
and so let me jump back then to uh
another conversation that i've heard
is state and local governments let me
just reassure uh
gentlemen you that the states and local
governments need an additional relief
my state does in the state of nevada for
the very reasons that i'm talking about
we have a budget hole
over a billion dollars but that's just
not nevada that's
all of the states there's
uh for additional relief for state and
local governments for the very reasons
that we're talking about
um and uh so this idea that there
are uh red states and blue states or
states don't either they're going to
misuse it i think it's a misnomer it's
getting in the way of really the needs
that we
have across this country in a bipartisan
way so
let me just reassure you governors from
uh republican and democratic states or
republican and democratic governors are
both
asking for additional relief for state
and local governments and we need it
for the very reasons i've just talked
about um but let me ask you this
secretary mnuchin jumping back to
the 454 billion that was appropriated to
the federal reserve's exchange
stabilization fund
is it your position that by the end of
this year congress doesn't make changes
or change of legislation that not only
your authority stops
but that you will actually transfer
those
additional funds back to the state
treasury
well i i've commented on this uh several
times already and i'll
repeat it again my actions are not
economic
it's purely my interpretation of the law
i think the section was pretty clear i
cited it earlier i'd be happy to follow
up with you or
anybody else on this and as regards to
when the money comes back
it's fully prescribed within the law
what happens to the money so there's no
discretion on my part
okay and that's what i want to get back
to because i absolutely agree with you
it's very specific in the law the
termination of the authority of your
authority
but it's also specific on where that
money is supposed to
stay and that you do not have the
authority to transfer it under this law
and i just wanted clarification with
that if your legal authorities are
telling you something differently or
your attorneys
i would like to know that because the
way i read it you don't have the
authority
to transfer this money back to the fed
under at least the cares act authority
so please share that with me
and let me just i know my time is
running out and i'll submit the rest of
my questions for the record let me just
say
secretary mnuchin thank you for your
service it is not an easy thing to do
particularly in this
atmosphere where there's so much
partisanship i appreciate we didn't
always agree but i appreciate your
service so thank you
i also want to thank my colleagues
senators mcsally and jones i've enjoyed
working with them and their
contributions uh to this committee
have at least helped me understand as
well
uh numerous issues that impact this
country in our financial sector
so thank you all again for your service
thank you thank you and our final
senator
who will be by telephone is senator
cinema
oh thank you chairman crepelo and thank
you to our witnesses for being here
today
you know arizonans are struggling to
make ends meet during the pandemic and i
regularly hear from families
and small businesses back home that are
concerned they won't make it through the
winter especially since
coronavirus cases are spiking across the
country
by passing the cares act and authorizing
the treasury department's backing of the
federal reserve's emergency
lending facilities we lowered borrowing
costs for households and businesses
alike protecting jobs and
stabilizing our economy as we continue
to fight the coronavirus
with cases on the rise now is not the
time to pull back critical support for
families and businesses in arizona
and that's why i'm disappointed by
treasury's decision to withdraw
financial support for the lending
facilities
particularly the main street lending
facility it moves us in the wrong
direction and puts relief further out of
reach for people that desperately need
it
so secretary mnuchin recognizing that
many u.s businesses need direct relief
as well as access to credit
do you believe that businesses
particularly local restaurants
retail businesses and those in the
hospitality industry
have what they need right now to survive
the winter
i don't i think that's why i encourage
congress to
authorize us to spend 140 billion of
unspent ppp money
so we can give them second loans that if
used properly will turn into grants and
save lots of jobs
well this is an area where we agree
secretary mnuchin i also think that
those dollars should be
released and used by businesses around
the country
i do hear from business leaders across
the state though that we need to expand
and improve not retreat the lending
facilities
and so i'm hearing from folks at home
that many small and mid-sized businesses
in arizona
won't make it without additional relief
and if they can't get direct relief they
should at least get access to credit
i think they should have both and of
course this isn't just about the
businesses this is about the small
business owners and the workers and
their households
there's a lot of stake at here and
families jobs and their homes hang in
the balance
you know back home in arizona most
people don't think that washington cares
very much about what happens to them and
my concern is that decisions to end the
main street lending facility
where where things are getting caught up
in partisanship and procedure
and people are losing in sight of the
end results
it makes me think that folks in arizona
might be right to have given up on
washington
now secretary mnuchin if you could just
briefly
respond to my question about the main
street lending facility we agree
on funding for ppp but i'd like to hear
your thoughts about
the main street lending facility and and
why you think that this should be
eliminated or ended for mid-sized
businesses in arizona and throughout the
country
well again my reason of why it should be
ended is because there's a december 31st
termination date in in the law i think
it's very clear
i've already cited the section i have it
with me i won't
go through it again uh i'd be happy to
send it to you
congress can extend it i personally
think that idle loans
out of the sba are more effective one of
the problems with the main street
facility
was that a lot of those small companies
are doing well had access to the banks
and the companies that didn't didn't fit
the program but again it was not a
judgment on my part
it was merely following uh what what the
law
prescribes now secretary i know that
senator cortez masto asked to see the
legal reasoning for
um your decision to end i'd like to see
that as well
you know we we have known about some
concerns around the main street lending
facility for
for months and in our last um time
together i
i lamented the fact that i believe that
treasury and fed jointly set these terms
too stringently
and that many businesses in arizona were
unable to take advantage of them so i'd
like to reiterate
that i believe that the program should
be continued and that eligibility should
be expanded for the facility
and the term sheet should be changed so
we can help more businesses in need
now chairman powell i've seen your take
on this and i know that
you and secretary mnuchin don't agree on
the extension of the main street lending
facility
do you think that households and
businesses will risk having lower or
higher informing costs because of the
um end of the main street lending
facility
actually it's a little more complicated
than that um the
the congress gave the secretary sole
authority over the
over the cares act funding we play no
role in that and that's in distinction
to
the 13th theory facilities which we we
design together because we both have to
approve
and the secretary made that uh reads the
law as
he said and it and really his voice is
the authoritative one on that and
we accept that except that reading of
the law um
so our point really was that that uh
uh other central banks and any central
banker would would tell you that it's
premature to be pulling back support for
the economy and the secretary didn't
indicate in his letter and it's true
that uh we can
we can either re-establish facilities or
institute new facilities
and we can even have exchange
stabilization fund backing for that
provided the legal requirements
are met i hope that's responsive to your
question
it is thank you i see that my time has
expired mr chairman i do have a couple
further questions but i'll submit those
for the record thank you
thank you senator cinema that concludes
the questions that senator brown has
asked for
a little bit of time for uh
closing remarks and senator brown thank
you mr chair and thanks again for
your service on this committee uh sure
republicans
told us today the only thing we set out
to do is to stabilize the markets
and we've achieved those goals so we can
add support to the facilities
look around us that's not the reality
we're facing in our states
people are people are dying in larger
numbers than ever before from this
virus businesses are still closing
restaurants
60 restaurant owners collectively told
me yesterday that it's it's worse
than it was in february march and april
people are
increasingly worried about the virus
people are still losing jobs they're
working at unsafe jobs
in unsafe and an unsafe environment
secretary mnuchin ended programs that
are still
helping small and medium-sized
businesses and helping state and local
governments he just simply
didn't need to do that thank you mr
chairman
thank you and
that concludes the questioning from
today's hearing
for senators who wish to submit
questions for the record those questions
are due to the committee by tuesday
december 8th
to each of our witnesses we ask that you
respond to those questions as promptly
as you can
i want to thank you each for joining the
committee today and for your service
and this hearing is adjourned
nice to see you
okay
you